Speaker 1: Joe Rogan continues this sort of like
turning on Donald Trump. Rogan now acknowledged
that he believes Donald Trump was regularly on
uppers during his presidency and called him a man
baby during a recent show. This is interesting for
a couple of reasons, which I will tell you. Daily
Beast reporting Joe Rogan calls Trump a drugged
out man baby. The Mega-Popular podcaster laughed
at Trump's inability to focus on anything but
himself in his latest episode. Trump and Rogan
now in, I guess, what we would call a feud. And
Rogan suggesting that Trump's energy comes from
Adderall, called the man baby. This was during
a conversation with comedian and frequent guest
Tom Segura. Let's take a look at this and I'll
tell you why it's interesting in a moment, more.
Speaker 2: About that guy is that, you know,
I'm saying even when you when you watch him
as president, he was full of energy, full of
it every day. And they said he slipped like 4
hours a night. One of those people on Adderall,
God did. He's on Adderall. Yes, I do. Only
because there were multiple people who
used to work on The Apprentice that were like he
was gassed up for shoots. Really? Yeah. Because he
has trouble reading it, doesn't he? He would
trouble he would struggle to read prompter
or script when he was just, let's say, sober. So
they would give him that and he would dial in more
on reading cause he gets he gets very bored.
They said, you know, he was he would get bored
at the CIA briefing in the mornings. He like I
don't want to read that there is a daily briefing
you get as president. He's like you, fine. Read it
and then tell me and if it's boring. So they would
have to make it more engaging for him because
he would I would put his name in briefings
multiple times to keep him interested. And then
Kushner, you know, his son in law, said that
he came up with a formula to keep him engaged.
Speaker 1: This is called the bad news sandwich.
It's often done in a lot of venues.
Speaker 2: Yes. Because, you know,
he obviously was close to him and knew him
well. And the formula was like the two good,
one bad. So they were going to give him bad
news. Like he'd go, You start with some good
news. So they go, This is going well. Everybody is
thrilled with you about this. Here's a bad thing.
Also, people love you for this. So that's
how you that's how they would tell him bad
news. They couldn't just get a bunch
of bad. Of course. Yeah. He's a man,
baby. He's a toddler. Yeah, he's a toddler.
Speaker 1: So there's two things here,
and I think that they're both important to
mention. Number one, whatever you think about
Joe Rogan and I have been very hard on Rogan.
We've done at this point what, 20 different
critiques of things Rogan has done. And when
that Rogan does something good, we will praise
it as well. There's no ideological or emotional
attachment to it or whatever the case may be.
Rogan's got a lot of Trump supporters in his
audience, and some of them are the kind of
they play that they're enlightened centrists.
Sometimes they even claim to read books. They
often don't, but they claim to. And a lot of them
support Trump, but they don't openly and brazenly
do it. But they do. At the end of the day, they
go, Well, yeah, I mean, I voted for Trump because
I decided at the end of the day, this, that, the
other thing, it is important and it is impactful,
particularly when the reports are Trump's going
to announce his 2020 for president candidacy for
president for the primary anyway very soon. It
is important that the culturally conservative
audience of Rogan not everybody I know there's
liberals who listen to Rogan. I watch some
episode. Sometimes the culturally conservative
people in Rogan's audience start to see
that alpha male Rogan is laughing at Trump.
Man, baby. Not a particularly alpha thing
to call a guy, right? It's quite beda. In
fact, by their nomenclature and standards,
that's a good thing. And it's a good thing
for people in Rogan's audience to see that.
The problem is Rogan supports Ron
DeSantis for 2024 at least. He said
he likes the Sanders. He vote for him like
some. I forget the exact wording, but it was
almost an endorsement but saying he would be a
great president. So one element is simply assuming
that this isn't all deliberate in order to prop
up DeSantis as a calculated thing. Maybe it is,
maybe it is. But even if it's not that
the criticism is all contextualized by
Rogan, like DeSantis, who's like an even more
dangerous Donald Trump. So is this a good thing
in the net or not? Is this sort of like a de facto
offense for DeSantis? I don't know. Trading Trump
for DeSantis as president. If you said to me
either Trump or DeSantis will be president,
who do you want it to be? I think Trump's less
dangerous because although he's dumber, he gets
less done. He's so unorganized and he's so caught
up in nonsense that I think he gets less done. Um,
so it's. If Rogan can disabuse Trump. Guests
are following Trump and supporting Trump. Great.
And if he can do it in a way that feels
like that better. TRUMP Now I'm Alpha,
I'm with ROGAN Whatever, whatever it takes
right to do to disabuse them of those
beliefs. But if it leads to DeSantis
being the next president or the nominee,
then we've got some real problems. And I don't
know the answer. I don't know where it's going